nicolas sarkozy rentrera donc dès demain
soir en france après un séjour d'un peu
plus de 48 heures en méditerranée au
large de malte
nicolas sarkozy avait toujours dit
qu'une fois élu il prendrait un peu de
distance pour se mettre dans l'habit de
président mais son séjour sur un yacht
suscite beaucoup de commentaires et un
début de polémique à gauche claude
gilbert le paloma ce soir au large de
malte à bord des hôtes discret le futur
président de la république française son
épouse et leur fils un univers luxueux
jacuzzi sur le pont supérieur cette
cabine pouvant accueillir 12 personnes
dix sept hommes d'équipage à leur
service un bijou de 60 mètres de long
dont la location selon ce site internet
frôle les 200 mille euros par semaine
une échappée de grand standing
parfaitement assumé selon ce partisan de
nicolas sarkozy
le message qu'il envoie aider totalement
clair ce terreau je sors d'une période
dans lequel j'ai été scrutés analysés
surveiller encadrés pendant des semaines
je me suis totalement donnés à vous je
prendrai mes fonctions dans huit jours
et là chaque seconde vous pourrez à
nouveau attendre de moi que je m'occupe
de vous voilà j'ai un break je suis un
homme libre je vais essayer de me
retrouver moi même avec ma femme et mon
fils est cette liberté
voilà je l'assument j'en prends le
risque le yacht appartient à un ami de
sarkozy vincent bolloré 13e fortune de
france
un empire industriel et de communication
presse télé pub et cinéma propriété du
groupe bolloré ce jet privé qui a
transporté les sarkozy jusqu'à malde
indignation de la gauche qui dénonce la
proximité entre le président élu et les
milieux d'affaires
allez voir les ouvriers taper dans le
dos des gars qui bossent ceux qui se
lèvent tôt le matin mon tout ça c'était
pour la campagne la personne n'a jamais
cru sérieusement que la droite était
proche des ouvriers c'est pas vrai bon
alors maintenant pousse tout ça c'est
fini et hop on en vient l'autre style la
droite décomplexée le pognon qui
s'affiche
you de lepost multimilliardaire voilà
quoi c'est pas le président a des petits
pots c'est président du cac 40 qui le
lui rend bien résultats répondre avec un
petit bulletin de vote
nicolas sarkozy devrait rentrer demain
soir en france
en attendant c'était au pas de course et
sous bonne escorte qu'il poursuivait ses
vacances ce soir au sud de mal